hello hello hello back in the saddle
again back to the sanctuary repeats
place back on the standout podcast on
standout TV hello everyone
today we're joined by our friend well me
inácio my sidekick change the narrative
man what's for the narrative to me both
partners in crime in it 50/50 thing
thank you
me and Ozzy you were joined by offering
we've all friend another person me up
with us today for my first start with me
only before we get started I just want
to say something I want to say something
myself personally so obviously I was
happy that introduction I was happy with
that introduction filming I just wanted
to check he's happy with that okay I
want to say something guys so obviously
we all watch TV we all watch power all
right
power is [ __ ] let's be straight on power
no we can we can get into this you can
debate this cool but I'm just I'm
nananana sports go for Anna's horse this
was stood out to me this week was
watching power because you still watch
it this week I still watch it because
this is it's like it's like listen it's
like put it this way if you're wanking
and you're thinking off way through why
my wank and you're still gonna finish
off the way too invested in power to
light just stop watching it
it is terrible terrible [ __ ] we'll
have to finish it okay
anyway this last episode I'm not gonna
lie and I don't care people have seen or
they haven't I don't care how many days
has it been out now came out Sunday
right watching power zone
so yeah anyway this last episode was all
about Tommy because they're doing a
finger I was getting their own episode
and it was actually really good it was
probably one of the best top if you had
to do a top five episode top 10 episode
of power he would be in there great ever
all from this season ever it was a great
episode it was a great episode we're
gonna digress if you go but what I wanna
say is well as watching it and obviously
everyone I feel I'd say 70 percent of
people apart from people that OH ghost
he's so good-looking
Tommy is your favorite character because
he's just sick he's real he's real the
way he says [ __ ]
everything about Tommy's wavy and
they're not just for at the end of the I
was how you know what Tommy is the
greatest TV character named Tommy of all
time
now you might comment you might argue me
and say Tommy show me these Tommy show
me them but I think Tommy Egan from
Power Rangers Tommy from raw brass I
went on Google today because bad way I
just wanted to say we just have fun we
just have cause we don't really do no
research we're just out here change I've
not lost forms yet I did Google
characters named Tommy Tommy and nothing
come up because I was like at least I
need to be able to give them you guys
just hit me with two more Tommy from
Power Rangers and was he just the red
one Ranger uncle oh boy and I have no
idea
something new every day Tommy right so
we're scrapping to me because over don't
know Tommy the main one yeah at the
Norman not the white me and say Tommy
Shelby bar I'm 10 you Tommy Egan from
powers probe's Tommy Shelby people only
like him because he's good-looking as
other thing that's what I mean I'm
watching I watch what Circle what's even
on peaky blinders I was saying I'm a bit
sick people is like powers or because
it's
program with good characters good
character is the actual characters
people like how many people can you
shoot yes some fake every everyday
everybody killed was six people six
people people on roads murdered but he's
real and I just felt an affinity you
know when you feel an affinity to a
character when he rode off into the
sunset regular house that I've rode off
into the Sun I just wanted to say like
you are the greatest Tommy of the rest
of Ingram I want to find me but he's the
greatest Tommy character of all time in
terms of TV is such a big thing now TVs
as big as film now about Tommy Robinson
anyway I'd say the Midori of where
you're from the reason why the majority
true or false
I don't know a lot of people did me he's
from Preston I always cease from mental
cuz to me he's turned on today with a
stellar energy the good stuff the
minerals
he's moved down to the Big Smoke how
long you been here for now - so he's me
dumpty of them really we're just here to
just have a chat the differences
northerners southerners why do we hate
each hey I like Aussies just you I know
there is some reason there is a ton of
his football ever bar just a difference
in how he feels you know living
here cuz I know you don't even like I
like it was I would have gone home I'm
right here I'm not healthier by I'm not
a hostage
yeah there's no jobs are I'm from so I
had to leave now aspire me to Manchester
from Preston because there's no jobs in
Preston unless I was like unless I was
gonna be like a builder or something I
was on a building site once for like two
days and I was [ __ ] obviously like you
work in media media in Manchester this
blown up now you know the BBC CNN finola
but why did you still feel like your
tomato job down here
[Music]
my girlfriend got a job at the same time
the trend we're educating literally you
just when Hotel know it photo you only
know it for really just like they like
it's the best face go for a now I've
been there for bit no obviously so when
you moved here you
no foolin yeah why did you pick no focus
up up see there's a north/south divide
going here
Pete see is a peeking up now he's out
now go stand off herself I came here
obviously moved with my girlfriend I
think I might have moved south
my girlfriend was just good all the time
when we first moved to we moved to Cali
Road like right next to there was like a
prison across the road from where we
came to who's on the earth was flat and
she was like I don't wanna [ __ ] yeah
and then we we went to Highbury and we
lived in like one bedroom in a nice
house in Highbury for a year no because
it would be add one [ __ ] room in the
house it was cheap oh it was like shared
accommodation it was like he was about
it still it was more expensive than I
was paying for a rent on a full but I
had a mortgage when I lived in
Manchester because it was me and more
expensive than that to just live in a
bedroom but then obviously the job
opportunity was sick from you being from
where you're from yeah my son to be
stupid but it's a bit it's rough it's
not easy going like no I mean so what
made London a bit more attractive
there's less people so if say bit more
scary for your girlfriend say if 10% of
an area is rough yeah but you live in
somewhere where there's only hundred
people and only ten are moved to South
London word is [ __ ] I don't know 400
files and people per square feet however
is yeah it's just a is rougher yeah it
is and and it's like you can't even just
living it in a nice area of a certain
bit of London because right next door to
it if there's a block of flats
everywhere literally everyone - I just
went before me I'll just went more trash
I've seen a lot of our life London early
obviously know the difference between
North and South London you know when
you're in South London and naturally
being from North for any way online
yourself sorry sorry I'm sorry when I
was in Malaysia and I was like hey this
place is royal and I love it eat chicken
bus December it was oh it was horrible
and there was some there was a homeless
man in there begging he was begging no
they were telling him to go he'd ask
people free time dear and some woman
bought him chicken and gave him a cup of
quid he was still up in there also he
got me and then just Utes coming in and
out every you that come in was looking
giving everyone an eye and I'll just
sigh and the tables with never again
that was that was nearly enough to turn
me vegan and you know me I was just so
just so disappointed I was a disclaimer
guys I'm eco-friendly I love people from
all areas please I've been more these
like six times and I've only had a good
one once
and where's Molly's predominantly from
the UK so you know when you and so I
think chicken shops in Manchester and
Preston's always have red salt and you
thought I asked you to bring this to me
where Himalayas yeah it's just that nice
more like like season so you kind of
like very very salt but nicer and you
get that in every chicken shot like
flavored so rather than just normal salt
and [ __ ] chips well you know you know
your chips up there just all fat cheese
french fry in every chicken shop the
French Rosie obviously can you bring me
red so next time you're gonna have to do
because you're not gonna believe me do
so in a short tequila
we peri-peri there will be nothing that
the Saltzman say tell about the whole
point telling about the chip bits I went
out with him before Niwas I do not grasp
scraps scraps yes you get like chippy
yeah and then you get scraps on top of
it which is like you know when you get a
fried fish and then butter falls off it
you keep all the bits of butter so you
put the crispy bits about crispy bits
that's the thing when I do like a chip
butty the phone when they put yeah chip
on cake it sounds wavy but you would
it's sick when does anything not taste
good with a little bit of butter
obviously a little bit so chips if
you've got a crunchy bit in a sandwich
and it's got gravy as well like meat
sauce it's mad yeah my one thing is when
you first come down there used to moan
every week I've not been in a proper pub
you ain't got proper pugsy seeds not
even the proper puppies I [ __ ] hate
all these bars that have like they don't
have normal glasses they always have
these [ __ ] shitty straight glasses
that make you be a pint flat so you want
a glass like the Stella sign on it you
want to be curved a little bit or like a
shape to it so that's what keeps the
fizz in it and it's not and it sounds
daft but it's true like you have a flat
glass it makes it flat yeah as well I
hate Camden Hills it's [ __ ]
and it's just everywhere because it says
come down on it so you all [ __ ] shag
to [ __ ]
is ISA fights and I might be sorry a
drinking Estela that's better in Camden
Hills
I don't like calm the nose especially
when you buy it in a slight always
expensive
Manchester's as expensive as London are
by the way so I've got really more about
two pounds you can still find them
places but if you drink in normcore same
price right for a pint as you get more
of them like banker [ __ ] everywhere
[Music]
Guinness oh Jesus man Vaughn shortage
you gotta admit me Watson to them locks
oh yeah yeah we walked into so many of
them laughs and I see what you mean
and you did you you can't avoid them
down here where'd you come in Manchester
you can't do every what about the people
because from my experience that I'd say
northerners are always welcome in so
everyone's always that all these
southerners are always [ __ ] mean think
we're above you yeah but you don't
it's like them lads then like people in
London those people obviously work in as
many sound people down here as there is
just the very vocal about it as well the
[ __ ] town and very loud if there was
that loud north they probably get slump
so would you say like there's a
different type of London or could you
tell if you met someone could you tell
all right this guy's from East this
guy's from south or these guys from
someone from West why cuz D because the
shock Howard's just none of it much
easily just they've just spent like 800
quid on an outfit for no reason that
kind of comes of experience of if you've
been here long enough is like there is a
way you can look at someone now you get
off that road man is from south or from
east of the make sense just because you
you've seen enough
uotto when after one thing you can tell
like like you booted easily decipher
like nothin easily you were to see like
okay cool
based on were just guys moving or I will
say necessarily dressing because that
could be anywhere in it but how
someone's moving back over there from
Northwest or deform East or themself
intuition if you've been here for older
people our age idea yeah I think I think
I could there's some people that will
just come up no I live for Manchester
next each alright yeah way but you can't
older you can hear that that's a
completely different accent
oh listen a little burnt Brahmin people
from bum have the worst accent in the
country sir who has a worse accent
people from burning not like posh people
from Bristol are the worst no no like
the Podge form the ones who are then
students like oh my god last night it
was [ __ ] mental
what do you like the best thing is
there's always someone to do you I won't
say one finger your hair cause
definitely better than when I first over
me this would affirm it's just a hug
when I was in high school he showed him
the levels I didn't show him levels he
showed himself I don't like I hate
central and because my girl works in
Leicester Square so I have to go meet
her after work I [ __ ] hate you in and
when they charge you seek squid I avoid
the tube all costs I get the bus to work
it takes me like 20 minutes longer I'm
not trying to say I'm better than you I
try my best not to I'll go and bus the
other day and I was I just felt
comfortable better than the tube proof
especially in winter it's tubes alright
summer because you're wearing shorts and
t-shirt and nuts you're not that hot but
then you have to wear a big jacket and I
got on a [ __ ] Piccadilly line
sweating you tit you know what I was
thinking today so obviously someone told
me there's telling me the other day
though a bigger lady going to to burn
she started crying and was but I was
thinking right if I was a fat chick and
people gay not live and not be like
thank you I'll be taking that like dumb
name rush hour that's why I was thinking
so I was just sad with that what would
you do would you like in that position
if you were a fat chick and someone was
that if I was a fat chick I'd hold my
billions but me but me and commuting
that's a whole nother thing I need
tonight I'm telling you someone could
make money um I haven't got the time to
do yet cuz I'm just someone can make
money for a year I'm telling you first
of Jan - first of Jan ride the night
train every Friday Saturday every Friday
and Saturday 24 hour just ride a
different line every train with a book
write down everything you see document
it into a brilliant book people are
buying that book and a laughing cuz you
are seeing it's just you know this ideas
copyright one everything that matter
happens on the tree telling you do it
like there was that what's that book
there was the number the number one
seller was um was that doctor that
documented everything that was going on
in a any for like a year
telling you but no one's gonna read
people about you seeing someone [ __ ]
themselves
Northern Line really people read books
I'm telling you night tales is someone's
gonna do it may be me one day
but I'm enjoying myself right now have
an idea for a gap in the market huh have
an idea gap in the market see you guys
talking about prices train how about you
yet get like four of your boys and you
take all the fairy seats right and you
charge people
are you trying to charge old ladies to
sit down it's already bad enough you're
taking their seat so how long do you see
yourself here for like you think you're
ever gonna go back home I'm gonna go
back eventually definitely yeah because
in terms of buying and stuff overseas
cheaper right would you buy property
down here um I've looked into it already
it's one of them were like just I can't
afford to buy any word it's not shit'll
and then so it won't make that much
money if I did buy it so it's not worth
it whereas if I the same price I could
buy like somewhere with a garden it's
more like I'm staying at least for
another year I'm signing on for another
year in March so I've got to stay for at
least another year and then after that
reevaluate 12 months maybe move back up
Master boy don't I do proper max it
might end up down here because it's just
ya know it's money darling I like to be
made where it's not there's no nothing
to be made obviously yeah because say
right say put a random number I'm on X
amount if I then if I didn't turn around
someone Chester Kristen say a random
number and I'm on X amount right if I
then turn around to an apply for
somewhere up north and say I'm on this
amount even if they're like oh we can't
quite much that we would go 5k on that
that would still be more than I would
have been on if I'd stayed up in
Manchester this entire time blah blah
blah yeah and it plus because I've
worked for this company up coming here
document because I can like job I work
for bur people now you can you can get
better
Jeanie's dhaniya my experience I'm gonna
come back with north more experience
than anyone who's just sat there in
Manchester sort of thing not anyone like
don't get me wrong there's there's a lot
of sick opportunities a blur but it's
just not it's better for me don't do
this now so so then money I think in a
long yeah you'd be fine now main
differences between like Londoners and
people know apart from that we dress
better and I feel like we take my utmost
to your girls as well I'm not gonna lie
from what come from my experience yeah
like all northern girls are that all
guys from London I don't know what they
see I don't know what they see to be
honest with you I don't know but we do
just start with you trespass on top tied
up like it's 2009 that we dressed better
[ __ ] off you know I mean in the general
London like has the South London
particularly Crystal Palace Academy has
mad amounts of professional footballers
compared to the north name one like
square mile south London's the modest
even like pressing off anyway sport
Daniel Johnson came through to policy
yeah what is that all about cuz you
showed me his idea
you got his ID what you got you go like
oh crap to that all coming in on this
like everyone knows everyone in grime
loves it is mad
yeah yeah think so but you still a
totally different scene oven isn't
because you're always know like right
there's no definitive difference between
us - you can't be like you're like this
I'm but that you - a Satya sipping water
I'm drinking Stella
that's one drink how many down you don't
know I've been caring might not be cut
out so that's that's Exhibit A you know
I'd say I'd say like you lower out here
the tracks using it you love always
stayed true tonight track suit fashion
know everyone's all contracts you I
don't think so
well why you know people stop rockin
track suits only in the last two years
and people start but he moans he's out
was food is tight kind of like tire
tracks yeah exactly known as this tape
do I not remember I moved out when I was
21 20
not lived at home for ages like
obviously I miss all my family and [ __ ]
and I bring him all the time speak to
him but I don't
I do sometimes when I go back to Preston
I miss pressed I think I'll [ __ ] I've
missed all these lot and I see all my
old mates and stuff are but I literally
go to one party every year and press
ENTER and it's always like the sickest
night every single time and I see
everyone but I never when I'm sat around
I never think I wish I was impressed and
right now [ __ ] fighting mr. jaws take
away all right so could you make here
home like officially no I'm not forever
laughs you know is it's the money thing
when if I if I if tomorrow I was gonna
be on 150 grand a year then I'd be like
yeah fine I'll stay in that sound yeah
because I'd be happy then the fact is
I'm not on the call when I moved to
Manchester I had to give up having a car
because I couldn't afford that yeah and
then since moving to London I had to
give up owning a house yeah I'm worse
off than when I was like I have my own
car and a king-size bed when I was 20
when I stayed at my dad's house I'm
worse off now than when I moved out keep
trying and trying it's eight years later
and I have a double bed that now I've
got a share my girlfriend don't have a
car I have to like use drive now zip
cause whenever I want to use a car and I
don't think everything else will go up
along with this would you say like
because obviously everyone has this big
thing about London you know only learn
it London was called the Big Smoke and
you said would you say like it's the
dream no not when it was
[Laughter]
so I've got another question here this
is going way of tangent cool I just for
this this is something I was thinking
like I have a lot of time to think
during my days obviously because he does
[ __ ] all the work right I don't just I
hear right in the way
so obviously 1917 just come out sick
film I'm telling you why do people
always oh because there were
institutional racism because also do one
secret since the world we're in now way
again I feel like basically they put
like a seek so I didn't even know that
there were different color soldiers in
World War one like that but I put a seek
so I don't know you know so they put a
seek soldier in with like the British
regiment and someone's saying that they
just force in mixed they've enforce it
like that isn't that didn't happen like
that they fought in their own I think
their own soul regiment they didn't
fight mixed with the British soldiers so
therefore sin and narrative on us that
the World War World War one was like the
British Army was mixed I just say that's
the one I'm not knowledgeable enough
about but I just think that's the world
now where like people were doing stuff
just to tick a box like they're making
don't make doper
they'll make basically don't make a
black person the main one of the main
characters in Star Wars just to take a
box when really and truly he had no
point in being in it anyway meadow that
John boyega was there as always it
[ __ ] the granule displaying about you
know now the stuff they do is not true
to their just do any justice Ichabod so
there's no thing behind it anyway anyway
we're digress from what I'm saying 1970
can talk about that later if you want
known for 1970 I thought I don't know
whether or not Indian soldiers was you
doing anything was mixed or not but I do
know the British Empire the time they
had in India didn't have independence
then it was still part of Britain yeah
yeah yeah but they weren't fighting
mixed on my rose and then the one thing
I'm saying is whether they had their
workers that was what in front I'm just
I'm just saying we're just through women
Indians where the Indian soldier was in
there or not I don't think it would have
mattered anyway and as I st. brilliant
film go see it makes you go see in the
cinema see don't watch out like war
films bro trust me to Eddie shows mad
anyway it mainly for it's all one shot
but made me think I was like because you
see lights or light the atrocities of
war is off your bill I read this that
was a bit deep cuz World War one I don't
think we're we're quite knowledgeable by
us is in school in that we weren't
towards much as we anyway while same was
what would you rather do
would you rather go to war or go to
prison
hold on a five years 16 straight in
prison Oh more chance of surviving in
prison then at war and if someone sees
you in prison and they're big that was
like war against the Nazis in like World
War two or one it's all right we're
going in just killing people for just
take oil to save people's refugee that
came over from Poland after World War
Two you yeah it's like if British
soldiers hadn't fought and freed him as
a prisoner he was a prisoner of war
yeah I wouldn't be
I'm saying well do one I'm rather go in
prison and big man can have his way with
me - I'm going to - I'm going to my what
because I felt like torture if they
catch you and need information late or
she doesn't long they're not allowed to
allegedly I'm just saying why I think it
depends what were you good - can I
simplify bullets go and pause the head
or don't drop the soap
what seems more scary right now in it
someone wants you to have you get thrown
about more than I know it's pretty much
the same right different so did you
actually think that they were gonna send
a letter for you there would be like oh
if they call you up do you have to go no
no yeah you do oh yeah
no no it was one of em he was like all
men
if you're not disabled or if you it you
can be where you like completely
objective warrior an objector so you
believe in peace and nothing but that so
you can do that but then I think you
still end up in prison then yeah if
you're all one or if you're like 15 or
younger probably 15 euros but like lying
because they wanted to fight for the
country so there was like I'm 18 just
going would you would you be like I
would have fight for my country
no not nowadays know if it was literally
like Nazism and like the way it was and
you it was about to get taken over and
it was just killing innocent people
no I have no I will never was that was
that wasn't strictly economically but
the only reason was up and now is to
make money for arms companies to take
right no no as someone who's been to
like no were ever ever uncultured yeah
yeah so if you if you had to use five
words to describe the north of England
who and you can't just describe the
weather how would you describe us
cobbles [ __ ] Coronation Street
Coronation Street is it five words we'll
just five things five five years five
words caboose cobbles
yeah dough dough
yeah just don't kind of gray gray
chimneys loads of chimneys just the
intro coronation a cat walking across a
brick wall chicks in track suits big
overt earrings yeah over 10 they call it
a bomb Birmingham see told you
Birmingham was no bomb bay silly base er
just was Judy sure and just pigeons no
obviously yes the oboe do like high
heels out and then just walk on but I'm
sure like northerners want so anyways
Essex will the chose he won and then I
rode top boy I feel like how we on top
they were fighting each other in the
hospital but depending the life he lived
though is broad daylight gold prison did
indeed only cane or web prison entire
thing Dave Dave he was just a coverage
to start imprisoned so the only of all
the [ __ ] in the first series he was
just shooting each other all the time
scorcher died yeah and it was all just
shooting each other how many bodies
dropped all that width of that happens
in broad daylight core I agree to that
definition I understand that people buy
drugs alone powers down and in fact is
like no well I don't know this for a
fact but no [ __ ] random drug dealer
from the street ends up owning 12
nightclubs and he's a mayor or some [ __ ]
like he's like this most people most
people up north right all also think if
you say the word bath instead of buff
people think you're posh even though
you're not push but you just hear these
sounds it sounds soft
my ear like a here pause I've grown out
one thing I've always said now when
people come to visit
I'm obviously London's my sister moé
import blah blah blah but if you are in
a real England real English people house
I'll under is no reputation of real
England and I think if you wanna know
real everyone which I'd say 80% of the
characters in Game of Thrones had a
northern accent and everyone's eye
Genaro me yeah but also different no
stay with me stay with me here stay with
me here I feel like when you like even
though it's a made our world that's sort
of a representation of my there 1800 and
the people that have is the water roses
yeah that's what is a representational
but but they switched it from Lancashire
versus yours to the novice so what I'm
saying is if you want to know real like
English people mmm straight-up authentic
English yeah but you should come just
I'm have to say you wanna now to
Preston's the war I've learned is to
stereotype is that people say people say
obviously people in Scotland in that
just think that we live so there's
another like 80 miles of England before
Scotland maybe maybe even a hundred
miles but you know I mean when I say
like the stereotype I know
you get paste you have a good night you
call it I didn't know that was a
stereotype that you even wanted to go
London centric with everything they
think about it they don't even think
when I seen Jay hosts the first boat the
second time I seen him was in Manchester
right yeah and he came out anyway what's
up in Liverpool a lecture like three
days later [ __ ] said Liverpool the
other day when I was in Manchester them
places are all the same to me that's
what he said that's how people think
they just don't give a [ __ ] if it's
above them that's why that's why it was
just a foot them and as well like the
amount of money that's spent the amount
of funding that like even things like
the studios and things that there's
there's no funding for music studios up
north and things like that and arts and
things are hot so that's why everyone's
like oh there's bear art is from London
blah blah blah it's like because there's
no money for that more because it gets
caught because London's what makes the
money since he came out he was never in
ever didn't have money I'm just I'm just
saying that there is there is a massive
disparity of how much money is get spent
on the art forms down here didn't
obviously there's more it's moved here
because of that so that's why it becomes
burning [ __ ] but I'm saying there is
like that does happen yeah I guess like
America and they it's a place where
people go to yeah of course and you do
that New York as well I guess we just
come to the conclusion we need to go up
north with Ober yeah I did yeah she
likes London a lot more than I thought
yeah bro Bolivia
Oh Monty if I didn't like it I go
happier and that's England's a beautiful
place we shake cultures all around and
we appreciate everyone's views and all
of that and I said we're just lazy we're
just here childish I did love it when
you get through a deep enough is
philosophical join us on the next
episode in the sanctuary repeats place
and we've got a new pod that's gonna be
on my support the dugout dugout that's
how it's gonna be out you'll be out by
the time this comes out though I listen
to the dugout great boys on they're
gonna they're gonna be banner in that
next episode laser should make you laugh
what premier league Managers can beef
we're not gonna get into that who the
toughest premier league manager is but
listen to that and we will see you guys
next time
cheerio